[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا وهذه نشره التاسعه هذا
المساء تقدمها لكم ميسونا واجد
[موسيقى]
خطط سلام صينيه في اوكرانيا تمانعها في
الذكرى السنويه الاولى للحرب
بدون ذخيره في باخموت وتحمل وزير الدفاع
الروسي المسؤوليه وتطالب بالضغط عليه
شعبيا
في ايران سي ان ان تكشف عن عشرات السجون
السريه لتعذيب المحتجين باشراف قوات
البسيج
وتزامنا مع التحقيق مع مقاولين بعد
الزلزال تحذيرات في تركيا من تسريع عمليه
اعاده البناء على حساب السلامه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم البدايه من الحرب الاوكرانيه
ومحاولات حل الصراع هناك اكد كبير
دبلوماسيين الصينيين
تتمن رغبه روسيا في تسويه السيراما
اوكرانيا السلميا مؤكدا ان ستلعب دورا في
تسويه الصراع بين روسيا واوكرانيا وستكون
موضوعيه وعلى حياد فيما يتعلق بالازمه
الاوكرانيه بدورها قالت الخارجيه الروسيه
ان موسكو ترحب بمبادره الصين وترى انها
ستلعب دورا مهما في حل الازمه في اوكرانيا
التقارب بين موسكوبيكين اكدته تصريحات
بوتين الذي قال ان علاقه بلاده مع الصين
مهمه لتهدئه الوضع الدولي واشار الى ان
الوضع الحالي اصعب بكثير بعد انهيار
النظام ثنائي القطب
العلاقات الدوليه اليوم اكثر صعوبه لم
تتحسن بعد انهيار النظام ثنائي القطب بل
على العكس اصبحت اكثر حده في هذا الصدد
يلعب التعامل على الساحه الدوليه بين
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه والاتحاد الروسي
كما اكدنا مرارا وتكرارا دورا مهما في
استقرار الوضع الدولي بالطبع نحن ننتظر من
رئيس جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه ان يقوم
بزياره لروسيا اتفقنا على ذلك في وقت سابق
وتعليقا على المقترح الصيني قال الامين
العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي يانس خلال قمه
مجموعه بوخارات المنعقده في وارسو قال ان
الرئيس الروسي بوتين غير مستعدا للسلام
وانه يستعد للمزيد من الحرب الامر الذي
يتطلب المزيد من الدعم العسكري لاوكرانيا
عام مضى على الغزوي منذ اطلاق روسيا حربها
على اوكرانيا والرئيس فلاديمير بوتين غير
مستعد للسلام بل يستعد للمزيد من الحرب
لذلك يجب ان نواصل الدعم لاوكرانيا وما
تحتاج اليه كي تنتصر ولا نعلم متى تنتهي
الحرب ولكن عندما يحدث ذلك يجب ان نضمن
الا يعيد التاريخ نفسه وشاهدنا نسق
العدوان الروسي على مدى سنوات
بتوازي تبنى مجلس الدمى الروسي تعليق
مشاركه موسكو في معاهده نيو ستارت وفقا
لمشروع قانون مقدم من الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين واتهم رئيس مجلس الدمى
الروسي
الولايات المتحده بتدمير بنيه الاستقرار
الدولي بتوقفها عن الوفاء بالتزاماتها
ورفضها لمقترحات روسيا بشان قضايا الامن
العالمي
اعتبر الرئيس الروسي حربه في اوكرانيا حرب
حق لاستعاده اراضي روسيا التاريخيه ياتي
ذلك في وقت قالت فيه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان موسكو ستواصل الامتثال للقيود المفروضه
على عدد حاملات الصواريخ النوويه في
معاهده ستارت الجديده حتى بعد تعليقها
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان نظيره
روسيا فلاديمير بوتين اقدم على خطا كبير
باعلان روسيا تعليقها المشاركه في معاهده
نيو ستارت لمراقبه التسليح النووي وردا
على سؤال احد المراسلين بشان موقف بايدن
من تعليق بوتين للعمل بالمعاهده وصف بيض
القرار بالخطا الجسيم وكانت روسيا اعلنت
انها ستلتزم بالمستويات التي حددتها
المعاهده الا انها لن تلتزم بها قانونيا
الرئيس الامريكي اكد على هامش انطلاق
اجتماعي مجموعه بوخارست 9 التزام بلاده
بتقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا حتى تسترجع
سيادتها وحريتها والدفاع ايضا عن كل شبر
من اراضي حلف الناتو
تحدثت مع رئيس زيلنسكي وناقشنا موضوع
الحريات والديمقراطيات في اوروبا والعالم
معا سنواصل تقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا حتى
تتمكن من استرجاع حريتها وسيادتها قدمنا
مساعده امنيه حاسمه لاوكرانيا ودعما ماليا
للمزيد من اللاجئين وضمننا حصول اوكرانيا
على الخدمات الاساسيه خلال العام المنصرم
بفضل دوركم الرياضي عززنا ايضا حلف النيتو
سوف ندافع عن كل شبر من اراضي حلف النيتو
وفي هذه اللحظه المهمه نتطلع لمناقشه
الخطوات اللاحقه التي سوف نتخذها لابقاء
حلفنا قويا ونتمكن من ردع اي عدوان مقبل
ميدانيا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
انظمه الدفاع الجوي اعترضت تسعه صواريخ من
رجمات هايم وعشره مسيرات تابعه للقوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه على مدار الساعات
الماضيه مؤكده ان القوات المسلحه الروسيه
قامت بتدمير مستودعات ذخيره
تابعهين في مقاطعه خرسون
[موسيقى]
بينما يقاتل مرتزقته في بخموت نعم مؤسس
مجموعه العسكريه الخاصه
على وزاره الدفاع لتزود مقاتلين مجموعه
بالذخيرات وذلك في دعوه غير مسبوقات تعكس
مدى التوتر بين المرتزقه وهيئه الاركان
العامه الروسيه
الاوساط الروسيه منشغله هذه الايام
بالخلاف المعلني بين الجيش الروسي ومجموعه
فاجنر اخر التصريحات مطالبه قائد فاجنر
بالضغط الشعبي على مؤسسه الجيش لتزويد
مقاتله
الدعوه تحمل اتهامات مبطنه لوزير الدفاع
بتعمد تعطيل وصول الذخيره والسلاح الى
جبهات القتال مراقبون يرون ان جدوى
الانقسام يغذيها تعطل حسم المعارك في
باخموت وبعضهم يرى انها محاوله من قائد
فاغنر لتبرير عدم حسم معركه باخموت بالقاء
اللوم على الجيش في موقف ممثل لقائد
الشيشان الذي حمل قاده في الجيش الروسي
الاخفاق فيليمان وزير الدفاع الروسي ما
يزال يلتزم الصمت تجاه اتهامات فاغنر لكن
الجيش تعرض لتغيرات كثيره لقاده المعارك
خلال العام الاول من الحرب في اوكرانيا
الصراع بين الجيش الروسي وفاغنير يشير الى
حاله من الانقسام ستكون لها ارتدادات مع
استمرار المعارك وهو الامر الذي دفع
بالرئيس الروسي الى توعد من وصفهم بالخونه
داخل روسيا بالعقاب
ولمتابعه الاوضاع في اوكرانيا وفي روسيا
ينضم الى من دونيت مراسل العربيه رائد
الاغبر من موسكو مراس العربيه عبد الجواد
الرشد من خركاز احمد باجاتو مفرد العربيه
ومن كاف حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه ابدا مع
رائد بالنسبه لباخمت كيف تبدو الاوضاع
هناك وما هي ابرز التطورات اليوم على
الصعيد الميداني
ميسون يعني بالفعل تطورات مستمره لا توقف
بالاخبار العسكريه التي تصلنا من ارض
المعارك المتشتته في جميع انحاء المقاطعه
اهمها باقمت حيث اعلنت قوات فاجنر اليوم
دخولها الى عده احياء في مدينه في العمق
في باخمت من الناحيه الجنوبيه الحديث عن
مجمعات سكنيه مجمعين سكنيين في منطقه تدعى
ايضا من الناحيه
الشماليه الشرقيه من مصانع ومعامل تعليب
اللحوم دخلت وشقت الطريق التي يسيطر عليها
الجيش الاوكراني وهناك قتال شوارع في هذه
المناطق نحن نتحدث ميسون عن عمق مدينه
بافموت وليس عن اطراف مدينه باقمت اي ان
القوات الروسيه او القوات الخاصه قوات
فاغنر دخلت الى المدينه لكن من الناحيه
الشماليه
اكملت السيطره حسب تصريح مؤسس
مؤسسه او مجموعه فاجنر القتاليه انهم
سيطروا على
بلده اضافيه في المحور الشمالي والحديث
ايضا يدور عن القتال في بلده اخرى متاخمه
من الناحيه الشماليه لكن الاقتحامات تمت
من الناحيه الجنوبيه ومن الناحيه الشماليه
الشرقيه قتال شوارع عنيف يدور وبدات
الاقتحامات الحقيقيه من اجل السيطره على
مدينه باخمه كل ذلك يجري وسط تناقض وتباين
ما بين الدفاع الروسيه والقياده في مجموعه
فاجنر حيث تطلب القوات مزيدا من الذخيره
لاكمال السيطره على محور باخمت وعلى محاور
عديده مختلفه لكن الدفاع الروسيه تؤكد
بانها تمد المقاتلين في كل الجبهات بما
يلزمه الذخيره وايضا من الجنود المستجدين
ساذهب الان الى زميلنا احمد بجاتو ليطلعنا
على ما يجري في ايضا خركاز هناك اشتباكات
عنيفه ايضا احمد ماذا لدينا في التفاصيل
كيف يبدو الوضع
نعم ميسون يعني بالفعل عده ضربات صاروخيه
شهادتها مقاطعه كما اعلن المسؤولون
الاوكران هنا انه تم استهداف
مواقع البنيه التحتيه واسرار ذلك عن اصابه
عدد من المواطنين
الجيش الروسي ورئاسه الجيش الاوكراني
والرئاسه الاركان الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن انه
رصد محاولات للتقدم من قبل الجيش الروسي
في عده مناطق ابرازها والطبع منطقه
كوبيانس الموجوده في مدينه خاركيف وكذلك
ايضا في مناطق بخموت وكذلك لمان في دنيتك
هذا التقدم تصدت له قوات الجيش الاوكراني
ودفعت بمزيد من
العتاد وكذلك المزيد من القوات والافراد
الى هذه المناطق في محاوله لصد الهجمات
المتتاليه للقوات الروسيه ايضا كان هناك
تسع ضربات صاروخيه هذا اليوم اربعه منها
استهدفت مدينه
ان هناك ايضا عشر ضربات جويه في مواقع
القتال المختلفه وفقا لقياده اركان الجيش
الاوكراني ايضا تم اكتشاف مجموعه استطلاع
روسيه حاولت التقدم في شرق منطقه في شرق
خارقيف تصدت لها المدفعيه الاوكرانيه
واجبرتها على التراجع والعوده مره اخرى
الى الاراضي الروسيه خرسون ايضا
الطرفين القياده العسكريه هنا تؤكد بصوره
مستمره وكذلك القياده السياسيه انه هناك
محاولات حديثه من جانب جيش الروسي للتقدم
واحراس تقدم لاسيما في منطقه وسيطره على
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها الان قوات الجيش
الاوكراني لكنهم يؤكدون ان ذلك لن يحدث
طوال عام كامل لم تستطع قوات الجيش
الروسيه
التقدم بالعكس نجحت القوات الاوكرانيه في
صد ودحر القوات الروسيه الى مزيد او الى
الخلف كثير من المناطق وينتظرون مزيد من
الدعم من الغرب هذا الدعم الذي سيؤثر
بصوره كبيره وسيجعل القتال يصب في صالح
الجيش الاوكراني دعونا نذهب الان الى
زميلنا حذيفه
لنطلع منه ايضا الاستعدادات للرابع
والعشرين من فبراير الذكرى الاولى لهذه
الحرب ماذا لديك حذيفه
مساء الخير ميسون لك ولي الزملاء اذا سمحت
لي ان ابدا بالمكالمه الهاتفيه التي
اجراها مع الرئيس الاوغندي وهي الاولى في
تاريخ العلاقات بين البلدين وتحدث
الرئيسكي مع الرئيس الاوغندي حول دعم صيغه
السلام الاوكرانيه التي تنوي اوكرانيا ان
تطرحها في الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
القادمه وطبعا هذا هذه الاتصال يعني يظهر
ان اوكرانيا بدات تتحرك بعيدا عن مساحه
الامان دبلوماسيا يعني اتحدث عن الشركاء
المعروفين لحشد الدعم لهذه الصيغه صيغه
السلام هذا ياتي التزامن طبعا مع صيغه
السلام التي تحاول بكين ايضا التحرك
للوصول اليها والامر الذي ينظر اليه
بان هذه الصيغه الجديده من بكين ما الذي
يمكن ان تاتي به كما قال لم تاتي به صيغه
السلام الاوكرانيه اما عن الاستعدادات
للرابع والعشرين طبعا تعلمين ان هنالك قلق
كبير على المستوى الشعبي وعلى المستوى
الرسمي من هذه الذكرى حيث يعتقد جميع ان
الروس سوف يقومون بعمليه اطلاق واسعه
للقذائف وللصواريخ سيهاجموا جميع المدن
الاوكرانيه كما يعتقد الجميع هذا على
المستويين طبعا على المستوى الرسمي
والشعبي اذا تحدثنا عن المستوى الشعبي فلا
يمكن اخفاء القلق الواضح بين المواطنين
حتى انه هنالك ترتيبات كثيره جرت يعني بعض
المواطنين عندما تحدثنا عليهم قالوا انهم
اليومين الاخيرين يعني الثالث والعشرين
والرابع والعشرين قد لا يخرجون من منازلهم
سيكونون قريبين من الملاجئ ام على المستوى
الرسمي في مناطق يعني الحكم المحلي فقط
اتبعت بعض الاجراءات كنقل الدراسه الى
الوضع الافتراضي اي ان الطلاب لن يذهبون
الى المدارس للحفاظ على سلامتهم في حاله
كان هنالك ولكن على المستوى الرسمي هنالك
حديث اخر تماما ميسون السلطات تقول اولا
ان الاتحاد الروسي لن يستطيع ان يقوم باي
عمليه اجتياح كامل البري كما حدث في
الرابع والعشرين في بدايه الحرب وانه
مستعدون تماما لاي عمليه مثل هذه وهم
يقولون يصفونها بانها ستكون محاوله انت
وانهم جاهزون اليوم علق على ذلك وقال اننا
جاهزين لاي عمليه هجوم تاتي من الشمال نحو
العاصمه كيف الهدف الذي لن يتحقق للروس
ولكن ايضا قائد القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
قال ان الجميع يعتقد ان ستكون هنالك اعداد
هائله من الصواريخ هذا الامر لن يحدث لان
الروس لا يملكون هذا العدد من الصواريخ في
الوقت الحالي قد يطلقون صواريخ لم تصل الى
المئه صاروخ والدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
مستعده لها مع سيكون هنالك اطلاق لطائرات
شاهد كما قال وايضا هم مستعدون الان رصدنا
الاوضاع في مختلف المناطق في اوكرانيا
سنذهب الان الى زميلنا في موسكو مداس
العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد لنطلع منه بدايه
على موضوع هذه المبادره الصينيه
بموضوع التفاوض بين او تقريب وجهات النظر
بين الولايات المتحده وروسيا ماذا لدينا
من جديد عبد الجواد ابرز المواقف الروسيه
تجاه
هذه المبادره الصينيه
مساء الخير ميسون لك والد زملاء طبعا
الخارجيه الروسيه اليوم على لسان متحدثتها
الرسميه ماريا زخرفه الرحبت
بالمبادره الصينيه لكنها تحدثت عن ان
روسيا الان تدرس هذه المبادره ولن ومن
المبكره الان الحديث عن اي خطوات مشتركه
او تجريبيه بين الجانبيه مضيفه ان موقف
موسكو وبكين من هذه القضيه وفي حل الصراع
الاوكراني والازمه الاوكرانيه يعني يجتمع
في خندق واحد ان صح التعبير لكن طبعا
زخارف على الجانب الاخر تحدثت عن ان
النظام كما سمته غير مستعد الان للقيام
باي خطوات استقلاليه يعني بشكل مستقل عن
الاخر وانكيف لا تلعب اليوم دور مستقر في
الساحه الدوليه طبعا هذا بما يخص قضيه
المبادره الصينيه لكن طبعا عند المساء خرج
نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي
وتحدث عن ان العديد من الدول الغربيه
بتجزئه روسيا واخراجها من الخريطه
العالميه بهذا الحجم الكبير لكنه اضاف طي
ايضا على الجانب الاخر بان الحوار مع
واشنطن بين موسكو والولايات المتحده هو
افضل من رفضه لذلك طبعا كما يرى الخبراء
العسكريون والسياسيون في البلاد الى ان
يعني بكين لم تقم باطلاع موسكو على خطه
التسويه لكنه تم مناقشتها خلال الطرفين
طبعا تصريحات السياسيه هي كبيره اليوم ان
كانت على لسان مجلس الامن الروسي او
الكرملين او الخارجيه او الدفاع وغيرها
جميعها يتحدث عن طبعا قدره موسكو اليوم
وقضيه ستارتين نيو وتعليق العمل فيها
لكنهم جميعهم يؤكدون بان موسكو لم تخرج
منها وهي ملتزمه حتى هذه اللحظه بالحدود
الواقعيه لها بهذا الموضوع
مراسل العربيه من روسيا اذكرك جزيل الشكر
كما اشكر زميلنا مراسل العربيه رائد
الاكبر من دانياس ايضا من خركات احمد نجاه
وموفد العربيه ومن كاف حذيفه عادل مراسل
العربيه شكرا لكم
مع قربي دخول الحربي عامها الثاني اختفى
الممثل الكوميدي زولياقا العاليه تماما
ليحل مكانه زعيم الحربي بل زمن الحرب
المتصلب حيث اكدت صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان
العام الذي قضاه الرئيس الاوكراني في
الخنادق جعله اكثر صلابه التغير في شخصيه
حسب الصحيفه
ظهر منذ رفضه دعوه بيلاروسيا لمفاوضات
اخرى قائلا لن يكون هناك منسك ثلاثه كما
رفض عروضا بابعاده الى بر الامان وظهر
كعدو اكثر شراسه مما توقعته موسكو حقيقه
رئيس مكتب الرئاسه الاوكرانيه اندريه على
تغيير المحن للاشخاص لافتا في الوقت نفسه
الى ان زيلنسكي كان دائما قويا واصبح اقوى
وعشان تعتبرت ان زيلينسكي ابقى على القضيه
الاوكرانيه حيه ببراعه ببراعه فنان محترف
من خلال القائه مئات الخطب مضيفه توصل لاح
عندي قناعه ان النصر هو الحل الوحيد
مستبعدا امكانيه السلام مع بوتين التي
تمسك بها حين تولى مهامه
[موسيقى]
لا يزال الرئيس الامريكي يعاني اثناء
صعوده سلم الطائره هذه المره في بولندا
اثناء مغادرتها بعد مشاركته في اجتماع
مجموعه بوخارست
في التاسعه هذا المساء نتابع بعد الفاصل
السعوديه تدين اقتحام قوات الاسرائيليه
مدينه نابلس وتطالب المجتمع الدولي
بالضغطي على تل ابيب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نستكمل نشرتنا من ايران
حيث حكمت ما تسمى بالمحكمه الثوريه في
ايران على الناشطه السياسيه الايرانيه
فاطمه سبهاري بالسجن 18 عاما وذلك بعد
خمسه اشهر من اعتقالها وكانت تبهري احد
الموقعين على الرساله التي طالبت المرشده
الايراني علي خمينائي بالتنحي عن منصبه
والسماح باجراء استفتاء شعبي يحدد نوع
الحكم المستقبلي في ايران
وعلى اغبيه المعتقلات الايرانيه نشرت قناه
سي ان الامريكيه تقريرا استقصائيا كشفت
فيه عن وجود عشرات السجون السريه لدى
النظام الايراني استخدمها لقمع المتظاهرين
والمحتجين وذكرت القناه ان بعض هذه السجون
يقع في مراكز حكوميه او في اغبيه المساجد
تتعدد الوسائل والغايه واحده سحق اصوات
تندد بواقع لا يحتمل في ايران يبتكر جهاز
الامن طرق تعذيب ممنهجه لفضل احتجاجات
المستمره منذ مقتل رمز الثوره مهسى اميني
سبتمبر الماضي شبكه سي ان ان تتبعت خيوط
شهادات اوصلتها بسلسله غامضه من المعتقلات
السريه في جميع انحاء ايران 30 موقعا
الكثير منها يقع داخل منشات حكوميه كقواعد
للجيش وللحرس الثوري الايراني والقليل
داخل مستودعات او غرف فارغه في مباني او
اقبيه مساجد هنا في شمال شرق ايران في
مشهد تم تحديده ثلاثه مواقع سوداء اليها
جر المتظاهرون مع سبل اعين وتعرضوا لضرب
مبرح وانتهى بهم الامر بكسر في الانف
احيانا في الاذرع او في الضلوع
المعتقلون ذكروا تفاصيل العنف الجنسي
والسعي بالكهرباء وخلع المسامير والجلد
والضرب المبرح الذي يتعرضوا له كل ذلك
تقول المصادر انه يجري تحت اشراف قوات
البسيج التي تتركز في قاعده النخبه
الدينيه مشهد سطعوني على فمي ووصفوني
بالسيئه وصوروني لاقول ان وسائل الاعلام
الاجنبيه اثرت علي للنزول الى الشارع
ليست فاطمه وحدها من تم سحب اعترافات
باطله منها تحت التعذيب في طهران بل الاف
المتظاهرين خصوصا في سلندر الغربيه ذات
الاغلبيه الكرديه ووفقا للروايات تمثل
المواقع السريه منفذ الاتصال الاول
للمتظاهرين الموقوفين لساعات او لاشهر
لكن مراكز الاعتقال غير الرسميه ليس
الظاهره جديده في ايران الا انها توسعت
كثيرا في الانتفاضه الاخيره
سابقه براي المحللين تعود لخوف النظام من
الاطاحه باركانه ما دفعت به لتكثيف
التكتيكات الوحشيه خارج نطاق الاجراءات
القانونيه وايقاف الاحتجاجات باي ثمن كان
مكرم حناوي العربيه
من اوسلو ينضم الى عبر سكايب عمار
الانسان الاحوازيه اهلا بك استاذ عمار هل
هذه
السجون التي تحدثت عنها
هي سجون استحدثت بعد الاحتجاجات الاخيره
ام هي موجوده اصلا
تحيه طيبه لك وللمشاهدين الكرام بطبيعه
الحال هذه سجون كانت موجوده قبل عشرات
السنوات وهناك سجون سريه منذ قيام انتصار
الثوره الايرانيه ولكن العالم لا يعلم
عنها احد وهذه المره الاولى التي يتم
تسريب مثل هذه الاخبار عبر قناه او شبكه
هذه السجون كانت موجوده في مناطق شتى مثلا
في منطقه كردستان وفي منطقه تابريز وفي
الاحواز ايضا وهناك ايضا سجون ومعتقلات
اخرى تخص بعضها تخص الحرس الثوري
والقسم الاخر تخص وزاره الامن الايرانيه
ولكن هذه هي المره الاولى التي نرى ان
الاعلام يتحدث عن هذه السجون وبالتاكيد ان
ان عددها تضاعف بعد هذه المظاهرات الاخيره
التي حدثت قبل برايك بهذه
تكتيك هذا العنف الذي يستخدم
والتهديد بهذه السجون التي تمارس فيها كل
انواع القمع حسب المساجين اذا خرجوا احياء
يعني يتحدثون عن انواع العنف التي تمارس
عليهم هل استطاع النظام حقيقه ان يقمع هذه
الاحتجاجات
بطبيعه الحال هناك اساليب عده
التي يمارسها النظام للضغط على المحتجين
والضغط على المعتقلين لكي يجعلهم يتنازلون
ولكن
هذه الثوره التي حدثت قبل اربعه اشهر لا
زالت مستمره او بقايا منها مستمره وسوف
تستمر لانه يعني الفلسفه والتاريخ السياسي
والفلسفه السياسي تقول لنا ان ان اذا ما
كان اذا ما اراد شعب ان يحقق طموح معين
فان هذا الشعب سوف يستمر رغم الضغوطات
ورقم المشاكل التي يخلقها النظام واعتقد
ان النظام الايراني هو ايضا يعرف انه وقته
انتهى ويلعب في وقت بدل الضائع وحد الان
لم نرى انه حقق اي انتصار او هذه الاساليب
القمعيه للتعذيب والاعدام يعني القمع
المظاهرات لم تاتي بنتيجه ولا ز
الشعوب والشعوب الايرانيه
استاذ عمار
ماذا تفعلون لايق
اف او النظام عن هذه الاساليب التعذيبيه
عن او لاغلاق هذه السجون
السريه هل هناك من جهود تقومون بها مع
المجتمع الدولي للضغط على ايران لايقاف
هذه الاساليب اساليب العنف واساليب
التعذيب من قادر على ذلك اصلا
نحن كمنظمه حقوقيه والمنظمات الزميله لنا
والتي نعمل معها من وظائف حقوق انسان
الايرانيه والمنظمات الحقوقيه الاخرى نعمل
اول شيء الى على جمع المعلومات حول هذه
السجون وحول هذه
المعتقلات والتعذيب الذي تعرض له هؤلاء
المعتقلين وتوثيق هذه توثيق شهاداتهم
وجمعها في ملفات
وتقديمها للجهات الدوليه ومنها مجلس حقوق
الانسان واللجنه التي شكلت من قبل هذا
المجلس وايضا المقرر الخاص لحقوق الانسان
في ايران وايضا لدينا ارتباطات ولدينا
اتصالات مع الدول الاوروبيه مع الدول
الكبرى ونحاول ان نتابع هذه القضيه في هذا
السياق والذي يهمنا هو ايضا جمع المعلومات
وتوثيقها والحصول على معلومات كافيه خاصه
ان هناك بعض السجون التي لا يعلم بها احد
مثلا سجن شيبان في الاحواز هذا لم يعلم به
احد قبل سنوات ولكن بمرور الوقت ومع تسريب
المعلومات
ويعني المعلومات التي
زود بها
الناشطين في الداخل الجهات
افقيه باتا مفضوح مكان هذا السجن وعدد
المعتقلين في هذا السجن وحيثيات اعتقال
السجناء الموجودين هناك واساليب التعذيب
وهذه هي كلها موثقه وموجوده
والمجتمع الدولي ومنظمات العفو الدوليه
ومنظمه حقوق الانسان مطلعه عليها شكرا لك
من اوسلو عبر سكايب كنت معي عمان حقوق
الانسان الاحوازيه
[موسيقى]
ننتقل الان الى تداعيات الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا في السادس من
فبراير الرجالي حيث قالت منظمه الصحه
العالميه انها تستفيد من توقف مؤقت
للعقوبات المفروضه على سوريا بهدف السماح
بتوزيع المساعدات الانسانيه بسهوله اكبر
في الدوله التي مزقتها الحرب بعد الزلازل
المدمره حيث افاد مدير قسم عمليات الطوارئ
لمنطقه الشرق المتوسط في المنظمه على ان
الصحه العالميه تتحرك بسرعه كبيره مع
شركاء الامم المتحده وتعمل وفق نهج جماعيا
لمساعدته المتضررين من الزلزال وضمان وصول
الامدادات لهم
فيما تسابق السلطات التركيه الزمن لازاله
اثار الضمائر التي لحق بها تاعي وباقي
المدن المتضرره من الزلزال تطفو الى سطح
الركام ماس انسانيه تحتاج الى سنوات
للنسيان مفرد العربيه الى هاتاي التقى
رجلا سوريا نجا من تحت الانقاض ودخلت في
رحله بحث عن ابنه الذي يامل في ان يكون
الناجي الوحيد من عائلته التفاصيل مع
الزميل عبد القادر خربوش
منهكا مكسورا فاقدا للحيله امامها للواقع
حتى وان نجحت خطط ازاله هذا الدمار الذي
خلفه الزلزال سريعا ستظل قصص ماسيه مستمره
ماث انسانيه لاشخاص امثال عمر ماتت زوجته
وابنه تحت هذا الركام فيما نجا هو ودخل
لحظتها في رحله بحث عن ابنه الثاني
المفقود
هاي لعبه ابني
والله لعبه اشتريت له يا بايدي
هاي لعبته
[موسيقى]
والحمد لله رب العالمين باتمنى من الجميع
ان يعرف خشي الاتراك صاحب البيت يشوف
هالمكان ويعرف يعرفني انه انا عايش اذا
ابني معه يا رب يجيبه او يعطيني خبر عليه
تمضي ساعات والايام وربما الاسابيع لكن
الزمن عند عمر متوقف الى حين لقاء ابنه
شعله امله الوحيده للحياه
عبد القادر خربوش العربيه
الطبيب قد يتسبب بوفاه شخص واحد لكن
المهندس المعماري قد يتسبب بمقتل المئات
هذه النظريه اثبتها الزلزال الذي ضرب
سوريا وتركيا يقول خبير الزلازل الياباني
يوشينوريت الذي اكد حقيقه خلال مداخله على
احدى القنوات التركيه ان السماح للمقاولين
ببناء الابنيه المرتفعه والتساهل معهم
تسبب بكوارث خلال الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
في السادس من الشهر الجاري الخبير
الياباني قارن بين الانشاءات في بلاده
وبين تركيا قائلا ان طوكيو لا تسمح
للمهندسين بالبناء فور تخرجهم بل انهم
يخضعون لاختبارات ودورات طويله ومن ينال
المرتبه الاولى يسمح له بممارسه المهنه
والبناء اما البقيه فيمنعون من ذلك ايضا
اضاف انه في تركيا المقاولون هم من يشيدون
الابنيه العاليه وناطحات السحاب ويكون دور
المهندس المدني والمعماري في تركيا ثانويا
وربما غير مؤثر ودائما وفقا هذا الخبير
بالحديث مشاهدينا عن الزلازل في اليابان
تقيم المؤسسات التعليميه بشكل سنوي تجارب
فرضيه لوقوع زلزال ليتعلم الطلاب منذ
صغرهم على التصرف السليم مع الكوارث
الطبيعيه وسنتابع هذا الفيديو من احدى تلك
الورش
[موسيقى]
هذه المقارنه تزملت مع تحضيرات داخل تركيا
في التسرع في اعاده اعمار بناء ما تم
تدميره خلال الزلزال وهو ما وعد به الرئيس
اردوغان الذي وضع مده زمنيه اقصاها عام
واحد لاعاده اعمار المدمر من المنازل
وافقت تحذيرات التي خرجت عن مهندسين
وخبراء بناء ان التسرع ينذر بوقوع كارثه
اخرى اما لم تتم اعاده النظر بعنايه في
التخطيط الحضري وايضا سلامه المباني وهو
ايضا ما اكدته الصين كويمين الرئيسه
السابقه لغرفه المهندسين المعماريين في
اسطنبول قائله ان احلال المباني المهدمه
هو الضروري فحسب بل ما يهم هو اعاده تخطيط
المدن بناء على البيانات العلميه مثل عدم
البناء على خطوط الصداع وتعلم الدروس من
اخطاء الماضي واضافت ان التخطيط الجديد
يجب ان يتصدر الاولويات وليس البناء
فجر يوم الاثنين السادس من فبراير ضرب
زلزال عنيف ولايات جنوب تركيا وخلف اضرارا
بشريه وماديه هائله المؤشرات والدلائل على
قوه الزلزال التدميريه لا تعد ولا تحصى
احداها هذا الصدع المخيف في قضايا
التونووزو بولايه هاتاي جنوب تركيا
هذا الصدع قسم مزرعه الزيتون هذه الى
قسمين بطول 400 متر وعرض 200 متر وبعمق
يصل الى 50 متر في بعض المناطق هذا الصدع
هو احدى الدلائل على قوه الزلزال
التدميريه والذي خلف حتى الان اكثر من
واحد واربعين الف قتيل في تركيا لوحدها من
قضاء التونوزو بولايه هاتاي زيدان زنجلو
عبر سكايب ينضم الى من اسطنبول المهندس
الاستشاري مظهر شربجي استث اهلا بكم معنا
ما المهم الان اعاده البناء بشكل سريع ام
التخطيط قبل هذا البناء وهل من الممكن ان
تكون هذه الابنيه مستقره اذا بنيت فقط في
عام واحد هل يعني اجراءات السلامه تكون
متوفره فيها هل هم قادرون على فعل ذلك
مساء الخير لك ولجميع المشاهدين والرحمه
للشهداء والشفاء للجرحى ذكر التقرير عده
مواضيع يعني اذكر منها
مراتب الهندسيه للمهندس ان المهندس عندما
تخرج ان يمر بالتدريج ذكره التقرير او
المهندس الياباني نعم هناك انظمه في دول
عربيه وغير عربيه تقول ان المهندس يجب ان
يتدرب لمده خمس سنوات قبل ان يقوم بعمل
هندسي لوحده يعني يجب ان يكون لديه خبره
وهنا يجب نؤكد ونعيد النظر بهذا الموضوع
اما الشق الثاني الشق الثاني من كان
التقرير
المقاولون هم طرف من من اطراف التنفيذ
البناء وليس فقط المسؤولين الرقم واحد يجب
ان يكون المهندس الدارس والمهندس المشرف
والجهات المسؤوله عن ذلك
يبدو بانه الكل يتحدث بانه المقاول له
الكلمه الاخيره الان في هذه الابنيه التي
سقطت في تركيا اكثر المهندس وهذا هو الجدل
هذا هو الواقع في تركيا نعم انا اقول يجب
ان يكون ولا يجب ان يكون رقم واحد وهذه
مصر انه لا يسمح في بعض الدول العربيه
لبنان الاردن المهندس هو المسؤول او
الاخير والمقاول هو من ينفذ تعليمات
المهندسين انشق الثالث نعم في التخطيط
العمراني يجب ان يعادل النظر في اسس
التخطيط العمره في المناطق الخاضعه
للزلازل او على الشق الفلق الزلزالي وهذا
التوجه ان يكون هناك مثلا في المناطق التي
ستتعرض يومها
المتنبع عنها يومي يوما ما زلازل ان لا
ترتفع عن اربع طوابق وهذه تخطيط عمراني
هذا ما كنت اريد ان اساله استاذ مظهر يعني
تابعنا هناك ابنيه كانت من اكثر من عشره
طوابق في هذه المناطق التي اسلم معروف بان
هي معرضه للزلازل هل هذا كان صحيحا يعني
هل كان قانونيا هذا الامر ام لا
ابدا الدعم انا معك اؤيد هذا الكلام ان
يجب ان يكون يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار المناطق
الزلزاليه وتهيا لمناطق في تركيا في مناطق
مختلفه هناك مناطق صخريه ومناطق غضاريه
ومناطق على الفالق الزلزالي ومناطق
انهداميه كل منطقه لها اسس تخطيط خاصه يجب
ان يعمل مستقبلا اما الشق الاخير التي
ذكرتيه هو هل يمكن اعمار بسنه واحده هذا
يعتمد على امكانياتها لديها خبرات كبيره
وشركات ضخمه في اعاده الاعمار فيمكن لكن
بدون العوامل التي ذكرتها تحمل المسؤوليات
والجهات والبلديات وان يكون المقاول هو
اخر من ينفذ ويعمل وليس المقاوله ليس لديه
خبره مثل المهندس تحمل مسؤوليه مظهر سؤال
اخير قبل ان ينتهي وقتي هذه المناطق التي
تعرضت للهدم هذه الابنيه التي تعرضت للهدم
هل من صحيح ان نقوم بالبناء بنفس المكان
وخاصه بانه ادركنا بان هذا المكان هش
وهو معرض اكثر من غيره لهذا الزلزال هل
يجب تغيير الاماكن
تغيير حتى في اسس التخطيط العمراني اللي
هو ارتفاع الطابق اذا كان منطقه هي
زلزاليه وتهدم بناء فيها عشر طوابق لا يجب
ان نعيد فيها ابناء عشر طابق يجب ان نعتمد
على الدراسات الزلزاليه ووفق اربع طوابق
خمس طوابق اذا يجب ان نكون حذرا لمستقبل
من هزات اخرى قد تكون بهذا الفالق ليس على
منطقه تركيا منطقه
الفالقون هذه النقاط النظر فيه كاملا وانا
نصل الى هذا الكارثه
المزعجه التي اثارت العالم كلهم حقيقه
شكرا لك من سكايب عبر سكايب من اسطنبول
المهندس الاستشاري مظهر شربجي على كل هذه
التوضيحات والمعلومات
[موسيقى]
اصابه طفيفه وجروح قابله للتضميض وان حفرت
بعقولهم نالوا الفرصه الثانيه اطفال
اخرجوا من تحت الانقاض ليفترشوا اسره احد
مشافي حارم في ادلب هؤلاء يرون بمن
يعاملهم من ممرضات حضن ام فقدوها او اخفي
عنهم مصيرها في عندي مريضه اسمها جنان
جنان جنيد هي من اطفال اللي طلعت من تحت
الانقاض هاي جنان عندي اياها يعني
كوني ما عندي اولاد فحس فبحسه مثل بنتي خط
الدفاع الاول في الكارثه هذه المره
تشاركته مجموعتان ففي وقت كان عناصر الخوض
البيضاء منتشرين بين الانقاض يتتبعون
اطراف خيطان علهم يجدون صوتا هنا او يدا
هناك تلتمس من ياخذ بها كان الاطباء وطاقم
التمريض على قله عناصره يهرع من زاويه الى
اخرى لمحاوله انقاذ من ياتيهم بعضهم لفظ
انفاسه الاخيره على مداخل المشافي واخرون
على ايديهم على واتعبيهم يجيبوا لي الطفل
فانا عم باخذه فبيقولوا لي عايش عايش فبدي
بكون انفاسه الاخيره يعني ما بعرف لانه
انا فقدت رفيقتي هون
راحت الضحايا الزلزال كانت ممرضه معنا
جابوا لنا رئيس المشفى فنحني عرفناه
استشهد الله يرحمه فتركناه والتفتنا لغيره
الله يرحمه ففي عالم لسه لسا عايشه لسه
بدها ايانا فنحن رحنا لهنيك الحزن المؤجل
رافق صرخه الخذلان فالاخيره باتت مالوفه
في سوريا وسقلتها حرب ممتده منذ 12 عاما
لتكمل عليها كارثه راح ضحيتها الالاف في
كل زاويه منها هناك من يبكي الفقد ويقول
لو كان هناك امكانيات او مساعدات لربما من
ابكيه ظل موجودا الارض خزنتنا
الحرب خزنتنا
كل الدنيا خذلتنا ما حدا اجا انقاذ كان
الدفاع المدني بالخط الاول
ما حدا اجانا من برا فخلاص وقفت وقف الصوت
الاصوات اللي نزلنا نسمعه تحت الانقاذ
ساعتين ثلاثه كان ما كان بالاصوات
[موسيقى]
عربت الخارجيات السعوديه عن ادانه وستنكار
المملكه الشديدين لاقتحام قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مدينه نابلس الفلسطينيه ما ادى
الى سقوط ضحايا واصابه اخرين واكدت
الوزاره رفض المملكه التام لما تقوم به
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من انتهاكات
خطيره للقانون الدولي مشدده على مطالبتها
للمجتمع الدولي بالاطلاع بمسؤولياته
لانهاء الاحتلال ووقف التصعيد والاعتداءات
الاسرائيليه هو توفير الحمايه اللازمه
للمدنيين
وكانت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه اعلنت مقتل
10 واصابه نحو 100 اخرين برصاص الجيش
الاسرائيلي خلال اقتحامها للبلده القديمه
من مدينه نابلس واوضحت في بيان ان الكثير
من الحالات مصابه بالرصاص الحي بينما اصيب
اكثر من 250 بالاختناق وانسحبت القوات
الاسرائيليه من البلده القديمه في نابلس
بعد اقتحامها حاره الشيخ مسلم وسطى اطلاق
النار كثيف
[موسيقى]
من جهتها حملت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه مسؤوليه التصعيد في نابلس
وطلبات المجتمع الدولي بالتحرك الفوري
لوقف ممارسات اسرائيل تجاه الفلسطينيين في
هذه الاثناء اعلنت القوى الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه الاضراب الشامل غدا في نابلس
ردا على الصعيد الاسرائيلي
في التاسع هذا المساء نتابع بعد قليل فطر
مشع تجارب كوريا الشماليه النوويه تهدد
الالاف بالغذاء الملوث
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال السفير السعودي لدى
اليمن محمد الجابر للعربيه ان الوديعه
السعوديه الجديده هي جزء من حزمه لدعم
الاقتصاد والتنميه وتحقيق استقرار سعر
الصرفي في اليمن
الحقيقه الوديعه هي جزء من حزمه من الدعم
التنموي والاقتصادي للاشقاء في اليمن
هو مجموعه من الدعم تتكامل مع بعضها البعض
في خدمه الانسان اليمني وخدمه الاقتصاد
اليمني ودعم مجلس القياده الرئاسي اليمني
ليقوم بدوره هو والحكومه اليمنيه في خدمه
الانسان اليمني ومواجهه التحديات الصعبه
التي حقيقه يعانون منها بشكل كبير جدا
فالحزمه مكونه من مليار دولار من المملكه
ومليار دولار من الامارات المملكه اودعت
بالامس مليار دولار في البنك المركزي
اليمني وهذا سيساعد في دعم الاقتصاد
استقرار صعب سعر الصرف هذا سيساعد ايضا
التجار ورجال الاعمال في القدره على
الشراء واستيراد وخاص المواد الغذائيه
الاساسيه
[موسيقى]
التجارب النوويه التي تجريها كوريا
الشماليه تهدد صحه وحياه مواطنيها وكذلك
مواطني الدول المجاوره وفق منظمات حقوقيه
بين عامي 2006
و200 2017 اجرت سته تجارب نوويه خطيره في
منشات الشماليه التي تكثر الى جانبها
زراعه وانواع متعدده من الفطر وبحسب
المنظمات نفسها مئات الالاف من الاشخاص
يعيشون قرب منشاه هم معرضون لخطر
الاشعاعات التي تتسرب للمياه الجوفيه
المستخدمه في الشرب والري ايضا العلماء
حذروا من تسرب الاشعاع من انفاق الاختبار
تحت جبل مانتاب مع تداولي تقارير عن موت
الغطاء النباتي هناك وولاده اطفال بعيوب
خلقيه هذا واكتشفت سول عام 2015 احتواء
فطر القنفذ
والمستورد من كوريا الشماليه لاكثر من
تسعه اعضاف المستوى القياسي لنظائر
السيزيوم المشعه كما ان ذلك النوع من
الفطر الغالي وصل الى اليابان دون ان تعرف
انه قادم من كوريا الشماليه وكان يصدر على
انه منتج صيني
[موسيقى]
عثرت السلطات اليابانيه على جسم كروي
برتقالي اللون على احد الشواطئ في مدينه
هاماماتسو بمقاطعه الشيزوكا اليابان لفت
معرفتها بطبيعه الجسم البرتقالي نظريه
اللغم البحري استبعد بعد فحوص بالاشعه تحت
الصينيه لكن نظريه الاغراض التجسسيه لا
تزال قائمه نتابع
[موسيقى]
رساله اعتذار الكترونيه اغضبت طلابا
واهاليهم في ولايه تنس الامريكيه عوضا عن
مواساتهم حيث اعتذرت احدى الجامعات عن بعث
الرساله للطلاب بشان حادثه اطلاق نار
جماعي كتبها تطبيق المحادثه الذكي تشات جي
بي تي بحسب صحيفه تايمز فان خاتمه الرساله
المكونه من خمس فقرات احتوت على سطر وعدت
صياغته باستخدام التطبيق واوضحت عميده قسم
التعليم والتنميه البشريه ان استخدام ذلك
التطبيق لكتابه رسائل تواصل نيابه عن
المجتمع في وقت الحزن يتناقض مع القيم
التي تميز الجامعه وكانت الرساله تعلق على
حادثه اطلاق نار وقع في الثالث الثالث عشر
من فبراير الحليف في جامعه ميشيغان وقتل
على اثرها ثلاثه اشخاص
[موسيقى]
تحولت مهمه لهدم مبنى متضرر من الزلزال في
مدينه ديار بكر التركيه الى مهمه لانقاذ
قطه عالقه في نفس المبنى حيث رصد رجال
الانقاذ القطه اثناء عمليه الهدم لتتدخل
القوات الجويه للجيش بعمليه انزال على
المبنى لانتشالها الا انها فشلت في
انقاذها في النهايه نهاربها داخل المبنى
نهايه التاسعه هذا المساء نذكر بالعناوين
سلام صينيه في اوكرانيا لا تمانعها روسيا
في ذكرى السنويه الاولى للحرب
بدون ذخيره في بخموت وتحمل وزير الدفاع
الروسي المسؤوليه وتطالب بالضغط عليه
شعبيا
وفي ايران تكشف عن عشرات السجون السريه
لتعديل المحتجين باشراف قوات البسيج
تزامنا مع التحقيق مع مقاولين بعد الزلزال
تحذيرات في تركيا من تسريع عمليه اعاده
البناء على حساب السلامه
الى هنا تنتهي التاسعه هذا المساء ولكن
اخبار العربيه مستمره مع 360 وطاهر بركه
وملات اخرى ماذا لدينا الليله شكرا لك
ميسون سنتابع استدعاء التاريخ الذي يحصل
يوميا بين بايدن وبوتين مع مراسلينا من
العواصم المعنيه سنتحدث عن موقف الهند من
روسيا وموقف الهند من الصين في هذه الاونه
وكذلك عن مدى قرب ايران فعلا تقنيا من
تصنيع سلاح نووي كوني معنا